خبر عاجل جديد كتائب القسام تقول استولينا
على طائره استطلاع للعدو كانت في مهمه
استخباريه غرب خان يونس جنوبيه قطاع غزه
الان من جديد الى مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام من غلاف غزه الياس يتوقف مع ما تقوله
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه منان المقاومه
تستانف القتال في شمال غزه و الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول انه يخوض قتال واسع في حي
الامل في خانيونس المعارك محت ديمه هناك
كما يتم اعلانه ماذا في
التفاصيل بالفعل ونحن ازدهار ما زلنا نسمع
ايضا الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله
التي نسمعها من الضواحي الجنوبيه لمدينه
غزه وهنالك بعض الدخنه التي تتصاعد من بعض
الاحياء في تلك المنطقه على وجه الخصوص
وبالفعل هنالك تقديرات لدى الجيش الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الايام الاخيره بانه في
الاماكن التي ينسحب منها الجيش الاسرائيلي
او يعيد الانتشار فيها يعود تعود المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بقوه اكبر وتحاول ان تملا هذا
ال الفراغ الذي يتركه جنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي وهنالك عتب كبير كما يبدو من
الجيش الاسرائيلي على المستوى السياسي في
اسرائيل الذي لم يحدد كما يقولون الوجهه
وجهه من سيتولى المسؤوليه بعد انتهاء
المعارك ال الكبرى في المناطق الشماليه
وفي عموم قطاع غزه على وجه الخصوص ولذلك
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه في الاماكن
التي ينسحب منها او يعيد الانتشار منها هو
يلاحظ بان هنالك عمل قوي من جانب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وهذا ما يفسر ايضا هذه
الاشتباكات التي نسمعها بين الحين والاخر
في جباليا وفي عموم مدينه غزه في مختلف
احيائها وكذلك الغارات الجويه التي تستهدف
بعض المناطق في مدينه غزه و كذلك القصف
المدفعي دعيني فقط اشير الى هذا الخبر
العاجل الذي اورده الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل
قليل في اطار الاحصائيات التي يوردها عن
عدد جرحاه في معارك قطاع غزه وفي اخر
تحديث هو يشير الى ان هنالك نحو
450 جنديا اسرائيليا اصيبوا خلال ايه
حوادث عمليات خلال المعارك في قطاع غزه من
بين هؤلاء
27 جنديا وضابطا اصيبوا بجراح بالغه
الخطوره ويت تتحدث الارقام عن ان هنالك
نحو
388 جنديا اصيبوا في حوادث تتعلق بسوء
استخدام الاسلحه او ربما المتفجرات هنالك
نحو 54 جنديا وضابطا اصيبوا بسبب ما يعرف
بالنيران الصديقه تبادل اطلاق النار على
القوات بين القوات الاسرائيليه نفسها و
وهذه الارقام ازدهار ربما تعكس حجم اولا
المعارك الضاريه وربما سوء التنظيم في
عمليه المعارك التي جرت في قطاع غزه على
مدى الاسابيع والاشهر الماضيه لان هذا
العدد الكبير نحن نتحدث عن 450 جنديا
وضابطا اصيبوا في حوادث عمليات او في
تبادل لاطلاق النار الصديقه هذا يعني بان
هنالك سوء تنظيم ما بين ال الالويه
المختلفه التي تعمل في مختلف المناطق في
قطاع غزه ونحن نعلم بان هنالك عده فرق
عسكريه عملت وتحت امرتها عملت الويه
مختلفه وبالتالي عندما يقع هذا العدد
الكبير من الجرحى في صفوف الجيش ال
الاسرائيلي في عمليات تبادل لاطلاق النار
بين الالويه المختلفه هذا يشد يدلل على ان
هنالك سوء لاداره المعارك وعدم تنظيم في
صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي وسوء في عمليه
التنسيق حتى بين الوحدات المختلفه نتحدث
عن عدد كبير للغايه 450 جنديا وضابطا
ازدهار بعض التقديرات ال العسكريه تشير
ازدهار الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي سوف يحاول
ان ينهي عمليته العسكريه في غضون اسبوع
واحد على الاقل في منطقه جنوب غزه وهم
يتحدثون عن العمليات العسكريه الكبرى هناك
نحن نعلم بان الفرقه 98 وتحت امرتها خمسه
الويه ما زالت تعمل في منطقه خان يونس
والجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه اتم العمليه
العسكريه التقديرات تشير الى ان العمليه
سوف تستمر لاسبوع على الاقل بهذا الزخم
الكبير الذي نشهده في الاسابيع الماضيه
وبعد ذلك ربما نشهد عمليات انسحاب وتقليل
لاعداد الجنود الاسرائيليين او للالوسي
العامله في المنطقه الجنوبيه كما كان
الحال في المنطقه الشماليه عندما اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي عن انه انهى عملياته
الكبرى لكن واضح انه بعد انهاء هذه
العمليات ازدهار عدنا لنرى تجدد المعارك
العسكريه في منطقه شمال قطاع غزه هذه
العمليات ما زالت مستمره حتى هذه الساعه
وان كانت بزخم اقل لكنها لم تتوقع من غلاف
غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام شكرا جزيلا
لك